Took Fendizal today for the first time. I felt a little off for a few hours, slightly
queasy and just strange. Is this normal? Just eat, it's best to just eat something fatty
with it or right after it. That will go away. I mean, I have not, I've had the only time I've
had people say that Fendizal hurt my tummy is when they first start taking it and then it will go
goes away. Eat some food with it, eat a fatty meal with it. That's what's best you're going to absorb
it better. It's going to, you're not going to have any, you're going to have less gut problems
with it. And quite honestly, having gut problems are feeling queasy with Fendizal is not a symptom
that anybody ever complains of except when they first start taking it because typically
they're a little nervous. And so it may be coming from that. The biggest thing that you
want to look at with Fendizal, even more so than I've ever been, is you want to keep an eye on
your liver markers because it can affect the drug. So it can affect your AST, ALT and alcohol
and phosphatase if you don't want that to go through the roof. So we just kind of keep an eye on
that and if your numbers are already high, we just don't want to elevate anymore.